dans la famille conway il y à la mer
kelly ann directrice de la campagne qui
apportait donald trump au pouvoir en
2016 et depuis l'une des plus proches
conseillères du président il y a le père
georges un anti trust notoire il a
cofondé le projet lincoln un groupe de
républicains qui milite pour faire
perdre donald trump et entre les deux
quatre enfants dont l'adolescente
claudia qui commençaient à trouver tout
ça un peu pénible le boulot de ma mère a
ruiné ma vie c'est ce qu'elle a écrit
dans un tweet hier quelques heures avant
celui de sa mère
je quitte la maison blanche
reconnaissante et humble celle qui avait
inventé le concept des fai alternatifs
assure vouloir se concentrer sur une
autre réalité sa famille nucléaire pas
politique
ça va faire un vide à la maison blanche
- chef de cabinet du président le
quatrième depuis le début du mandat
avec le départ de kelly ann conway le
roulement de personnel dans l'équipe
trump atteint 91% neuf conseillers sur
dix ont quitté leur poste
georges conway prend lui aussi ses
distances avec le groupe lincoln et le
mouvement never trempe un mouvement qui
reste minoritaire puisque 95% des
républicains disent encore vouloir voter
pour donald trump selon un sondage cnn
ici mathieu prost radio canada montréal